so I see this in the New York Post New
York women are charging men up to three
thousand dollars for failed
relationships and bad dates I'm like
come on and you see dbag tax 2500 bucks
no joke so you read it and you get into
the stories
um and this girl Duke Martha Duke 38
years old by the way says no joke she
sent around six venmo requests ranging
from fifteen hundred to three thousand
dollars depending upon the guy's
financial situation she assessed the
situation over the years to different
men she's dated she listed infidelity
secret marriages and hiding having
multiple sexual partners from her as
some of the reasons for the change so
she decided that this guy had done her
wrong done her dirty and she sent him a
venmo and let guys you ready the guys
are paying it the guys are all paying it
I'm not saying it's right to be to cheat
I'm not saying it's right to hide your
marriage I'm not saying any of these
things are right I'm not condoning them
but somebody sends you this tax and
you're like okay I guess I gotta pay
three thousand but what are you buy in
some silence or what's going on here
what's going on so and then it goes on
it says she says that the venmo requests
have been cathartic and she submitted
them to Men Who offered her who offended
her in various various ways another one
Hazel ever 34 agreed saying she sent a
venmo request to a man she'd been seeing
for several months after he stopped
communicating with her and sent her
another woman's nude photos not a good
idea guys just saying I just went on
venmo and I requested a hundred dollars
and for the Highlight I wrote for
wasting my time
although initially surprised her former
partner paid the money stating her
reasoning behind the charge being the
significant time and effort into their
relationship so the guys are paying so
people have lost their minds whatever
happened to call me old-fashioned
whatever happened to you date somebody
they do you wrong you leave them and you
move on am I just am I too old school
for this game Ally I mean I don't
understand should I have been sending
venmo requests for 1500 and up to guys
that did me dirty over the years no
that's just it's way too much
entitlement no and that's why you're
married that's probably why I married
too that doesn't make any sense because
what I saw was two Dusty broads who
can't get it on a good day This Woman's
been dating for 38 years she hasn't
figured out she's the problem and she's
like oh like well let me just let me
just send them a tax other chicks 34.
like two Dusty women that are just gonna
die alone invest into e shout out to
freshman
no oh my gosh it's horrible and you're
gonna make a man pay because you had a
bad time on a day with him what what if
men came out you know yeah matter of
fact men if you're watching do me a
favor send a venmo to the last bad date
that you went on with a woman I'm sure
it I'm sure they would come out in
droves if they just have the confidence
but I think it's really sad and pathetic
too and I do believe that these men are
basically simping because they're paying
for a chance and the hope of the cookie
again if they even got access to it
doesn't make any sense to me and women
that play men financially in that way
you're not playing men that are worth
anything they're substantial worthwhile
just good quality men because a good
quality man wouldn't would he would
laugh at you he'd be insulted by he
would block you so you're not getting
over on good quality men you're getting
over on betas and if you take pride in
gaming a beta fine like why don't you
try gaming an alpha that might be more
fun and more interesting that women have
game though so I don't know the women
would never pay this though you said if
it was reverse you're like I'm not gonna
pay that they wouldn't be so insulted
and they would send screenshots all over
their Instagram that's why I think men
should do it like y'all really should
venmo these women that you have bad
dates with just to see the outrage and
be great oh man only in New York City
Tyler these things Kitty can you imagine
can you imagine going on a bad date with
somebody or something goes on and they
and you all of a sudden something pops
in your phone and it's like 200 bucks
because you didn't behave a certain way
I mean can you even imagine they got
gonads these women gonads I'm just
saying oh my God I'm looking at this
girl Martha Duke and I'm thinking she
must have a wonderful personality
the coup in their right mind well that's
like that look 500 no no that's that
like hippie she probably lives in like
crazy theater girl she lives in Brooklyn
five cats if you want to watch the full
episode you're going to click right here
and if you want to ask me a question one
on one you want to do a one-on-one
FaceTime with a group of your friends
whatever you want you need to download
right now click right here and let's get
talking
foreign
[Music]